[Music]
jyllian podcast sorry my eyes already
just put my contact a like really hurt
just in my left eye sorry
you feel me people that wear contacts
cannot relate welcome back everybody
this episode is brought to you by stitch
fix now available ok whoa Citrix is a
service that fixes you up with the best
stitches clothing good one it's an
online personal styling service is very
cool you enter your style preferences
and they send you a box of really cool
clothes and you keep what you want no
subscription required just go to stitch
fix comm slash Jenna Julianne for an
extra 25 percent off and you keep
everything in your box stitch fixed comm
slash annejulien or click the link down
below also guys this skin it is an
awesome way to wake up with knowledge
and information that doesn't overwhelm
you but helps you go about your day and
a more educated and aware manner it is a
little newsletter that comes completely
for free to your email every morning and
in five minutes you can skim over the
most important news that there is out
that day so check it out by going to the
skim th es k IM m.com slash energy
leonine to your email click and you're
subscribed it's completely free also
you're entered to win a $250 Visa gift
card when you do that click link down
below to get started thank you sponsors
what are we doing today so you remember
the time when I played you movie theme
songs and you had to guess then what if
you guessed video game theme songs come
right so okay well here's the thing
disclaimer there are so many yeah yeah I
got copy copy struck as soon as the
thought crossed my mind there are so
many games and I did my best to put like
some old games some new games many of
which you are not gonna know but this is
also for our listeners so that you can
play along yeah you guys play along with
me okay so we can compare
and then decide at the end who is better
over seriously don't get frustrated
because they're like I don't know these
know I know the people I'm expecting to
get like a small handful of them yeah
and also don't think of me as any less
of a gamer I'm a gamer gamers I know
like for theme songs I know like Halo
pub G and and maybe one of the Mario so
that's it
Pokemon - okay the rest no actually I
don't know we'll see I'm excited though
because do you have you have a point in
the middle where you wanted to stop me
in a trade sponsor sorry no sorry sorry
yeah just do it help me keep track of
time but I I think I mean as long as
we're on going through them one a second
I think we should have like way more
than enough okay but um it should be fun
yeah no I'm excited
I've had a good time going through them
yeah it was it was it rainy them really
nostalgic at all or no yeah of course
well I don't know you know you you know
what kind of games you played growing up
for whatever well the games that I
played growing up I did not include in
here because I don't think a lot of
people played King's Quest v vana no no
I'm sure a little computer did you guys
play King's Quest 5 please comment down
below if you played it Jenna needs to
moans let me know if you played you play
with your friends growing up matterhorn
or the Monty Python game or any other
like DOS or whatever cut but yeah I mean
I tried to do my best
we probably could make like I don't know
how many podcasts of guessing theme
songs because there's literally a
bajillion video games so I apologize if
you're sitting here waiting for your
favorite game theme to play and I don't
play it she apologize I apologize but
are you ready I'm [__] ready let's do
this it's fun it's a good toss to it I
love this stuff because I love the music
in games so much I know just like I love
the music in movies so much it's it's
just my favorite thing I you know what
maybe someday I can actually turn into
more of a sound engineer and learn how
to control stuff like this through
the system so we don't have to bring our
laptop and they can actually play
through but yeah with it right now
you'll have to listen to the audio based
off of Jenna's laptop I feel like in a
different life if I really stuck with
music when I was younger I feel like
this would have been my dream job
composing music for the video games
really yeah a lot of interesting except
people would be like alright make us
something for this like scary game and I
come up with like the derpiest theme
you've ever heard they're like you're
fired and I'm like [__] I can't stop
making really Darby music I miss your
music you make good music thanks Beach
okay okay hit me you don't get this and
no cheating if you look at my car you
never cheated on their game ever dude
you were always cheat you look at my
screen hey you can't do that thing where
you can't do that thing when you play
two seconds and you look at me and do
not start this game off on a hostile no
this is really calming fun nostalgic
music for people who can't do the thing
where you start the song and if I don't
get it instantly you look at me and
you're like oh my god how are you not
getting it how am I supposed to knock it
I'm talking that's rude
[Music]
how's it going anywhere hey what the
hell no like is it picking up or is this
kind of it no do you want a hint
yeah so this game is starring one of
everyone's favorite characters he has a
brother Mario yeah so this is a vertices
of Mario game was it
it had a controller it's not Super Mario
there's not Superman do you have a guess
as to like what kind of Mario level this
music would play in an underwater level
yeah
is it super what Super Mario the
underwater levels no well it is Super
Mario is it but it was on n64 yeah did
you ever play that I never had an n64
but is it the one where you run around
the world and you're it's like a third
person game are you running around yeah
yeah what is that one called Mario World
Super Mario 64 I'm a Mario Mario little
Mario in a big world I'm Mario Super
Mario 64 I never played it I never
played it really yeah I only played um I
only played Mario on Super Nintendo
which was the 2d platformer just you
were asking if it went anywhere this is
where it's going
[Music]
I never play that game that's crazy to
me you know I know about I played at
friends houses my friends played but I
never had an n64 and so I never really
got familiar with that game I replayed
the whole thing on my yes really
yeah you remember that uh what was that
was that after we got done playing Mario
Party and you just went off on your own
and played that one yeah how would I
remember that because I was tired I was
tired of beating all my friends in the
Mario Party toxic says miss I don't want
to get a switch because I don't want to
play Mario Party ever a party alone I
like playing with my friends what we
have are you ready we have a lot of
songs to get to right we'll pick it up
back to one all right
[Music]
I have no idea I know you haven't played
this game is it um the mobile app for
the TV show Survivor is it the mobile
app game
first is it survivor the game can I get
a hint I have it now okay there's the
cowboy have red dead yeah is red dead
redemption - - it's been so long been so
long what oh I only play the first one
does that go on it's out on pc we should
play it okay I hear it's really good
me too that was for our listeners RDR -
alright
hey though Julian here's your next one
[Music]
this song is the bane of my whole
existence this is the soundtrack to my
life in the morning at night in the
middle of the day during meals bathroom
breaks every single time of the day I'm
hearing this son this is hearthstone
because jenna plays on her phone and
then it says victory because she just
beats her own ass grab on space by the
heart as that he says look like that go
on in here and you're like no all right
sorry
alright Julian here you go here's your
next one
No
[Music]
see this is you know what else is gonna
happen what is I'm gonna hear something
and it's gonna be so familiar and in my
face that I'm gonna be like I don't know
what it is do you know I mean and it's
happening currently so don't laugh at me
cuz I'm fully blanking on this even
though obviously no it
[Music]
okay is this the old pub jiseong no all
right what is this we've played this
game a lot
is it a mobile game yeah it is
is it only a mobile you know poor night
yeah it's for night ah see you know I
was getting there as the Battle Royale
how did you know as a sneeze oh okay
yeah sure next guys it's a lot easier in
the audience and in the hot see I know
you're making fun of me okay go
I don't think you played this game but I
don't know
[Music]
take it the genre
I guess them killing stuff was it doom
now it's not doing is it is they're
aliens Indiana Jones the video game what
is it this is the combat music from The
Witcher 3 never played though what
you're serious yeah I'm sure a lot of
people did though shots out so later if
you didn't you don't get a shout-out oh
I don't get a shot and play The Witcher
cool
[Music]
Pokemon
I felt as Pokemon
there's none Pokemon
[Music]
oh c'mon double tank
Pokemon Arena no Super Smash Bros
Pokemon edition though that yeah that's
over
Zelda oh god okay I need that one I did
I knew that one good job
well very patty thank you you got there
you know going so badly doesn't matter
how you start matters how you finish
first play I'm ready
Julian go ahead
oh so bored it's so annoying
or in the blind forest no that's not a
bad guess though yeah let me skip
[Music]
badlands oh it's the light one who uh
you played this game you played this
game I played this game I played this
man you play this game I play this game
you play this game play is in current no
no no
subnautica know you never bleed I play
subnautica and this is not a gamer keep
going
I'm skipping around
is it the Zelda purse which no I don't
currently play this game okay I don't
hear these sounds for sure toxic it's
not a game that you spent hours mining
in oh it's minecraft it's minecraft I
turned off music I turned off music in
Minecraft so I can play my own that's
why I didn't recognize this got it okay
I did put a lot of hours into Minecraft
I did okay are you ready for your next
yeah I hope some someone else got it out
there because I like I wouldn't have
gotten it if put on the spot to guess it
but now that you know it's minecraft you
literally never you're like mining and
then the music comes in all quiet like
that no I literally I remember when we
first started and I went in audio
settings and muted all game music
because I didn't want it to clash what
the music I was playing
well gee
hell yeah this is this is the song of my
theme is a whole theme song oh my god
this brings me back with that old menu
with the a K that's like as tall as a
person on the left wall Oh guys we've
spent so many hours in this game one
hour why not one like for one like
equals one pair equals one hour how many
hours you I don't know I'd have to check
my Steam but a lot thousands mm-hmm I
think either two or three thousand men
care about three thousand I have like I
don't know four five hundred less than
you but so if you had three thousand I
have 2,500 start right play a little
before you like yeah mm-hmm
[Music]
Papa pair clothes
candy crush yeah [__] candy crush the
original candy crush music is so
obnoxious
[Music]
[__] it up [__] it up
hey hey hey oh [__] oh why does it feel
like this is the first time you've ever
heard this might be just sounds like an
old game is it old yeah it's laps though
still to this day hint so it's around at
the same time this Mario huh
he exists yes I had a feeling it was
Donkey Kong you play Donkey Kong drop
yeah but it wasn't at my house I played
at my friend's house Donkey Kong was a
[__] game superintendent yeah yeah
that's when we had to yeah yeah Hong
Kong superintend it was a lot of fun oh
yeah
[Music]
Mario Kart
oh my god I know this miss Pokemon
oh my god dude that be that being
getting sounded like Mario Kart at the
start of the race
yeah I didn't realize that the song
started off like this
cuz I know this part but I didn't never
remember the beginning oh this really
[__] bringing me back did you play
pokemon growing up ever no you never had
a gameboy I had a game where I didn't
played Pokemon why why is that
why to make that choice I played Tetris
and I played Mario you would play Tetris
that's a very genin
what no that's not an insult
I love judging no you you that is yours
like I can see why that's your [__] like
that's your style of you just want to
get it [__] right in there no it's
cute halo no you did that was an
uneducated guest truly touching their
leg
don't think I contacted me and then
slowly look like
[Music]
stop touching my nose he's holding
the room I don't I don't know the room
yeah isn't that a game plan you fall in
the puzzle game yeah I love that game
but no have I played this game yes I
have yes in the last year yes
it's America no skipping around Carla is
the counter it's not Conan
[Music]
I need more hints I'm not getting
there's not any indication of like
search for a bomb or anything right now
ch yeah it's a siege yes are you not
picking your character right here in
this music I'm not even gonna lie I
think I have siege music turned off too
no I swear to God I don't like I swear
to God I think I have it turned off
because I play music on stream so any
game that has like like menu music I
turn off why are you looking me like
that I thought you were gonna get that I
don't think I've ever even heard that
song Wow like the fort night menu the
pub key menu all very familiar because
I've never turned those off because
you're only in the menu whatever I don't
know I guess the music never really
bothered me but for siege I'm pretty
sure I turned off the music because I've
never heard that song got it okay next
one
[Music]
is that it Oh your hint is that we
played this for a little bit then we
didn't finish it last of us yeah how'd
you know that um
because I've watched people play it yeah
and I remember the beginning I hear that
we should really give it a shot you know
here it's a gory and this second one
just came out right I think so yeah yeah
- jeez
Jesus what was his name Caleb life is
strange
no his life is strange this is like his
strange life is rain
[Music]
what are you doing well why can't we get
your phone
stop looking stop what
check your phone Julian don't text me
just check it it Texas we could light
this strange question mine
stop no you're ruining the game for
people that was Assassin's Creed to an
earthly I know cuz that doesn't mean
that you have to make it not fun for
people listening by yelling and texting
life is strange it sounds let's not even
life is strange how are you know we did
is beginning did no way the beginning
play being no that was the beginning I
gave my all right shut up just shut up
Julian
[Music]
[__] hallo
you're gonna text do you life is strange
again I'm not checking my phone again if
you text it one more time I'm not
looking what are this emergency why do
your eyes cross what do you mean okay
wait what okay for for the viewers at
home no for our twitch followers who are
watching will you agree to play some of
this with me when it comes out on pc do
you agree just say it out loud yes I
agree
if keep playing it then no here's your
next one
[Music]
you did play this game
don't look at my laptop
[Music]
subnautica all right no no I'm sorry
I'll keep playing Elmo's more helpful I
mean it sounds a little like Game of
Thrones
[Music]
it sounds sad
sounds like a sad game why'd you stop
that I didn't I'm skipping around for
you because a lot of these are like
they'll compile you know a video game
has a lot of music so you know this
might be one part of the game
skipping around so maybe you can hear
something that sounds familiar to you
I'm just trying to do a good job of
thinking what games I've played like on
stream recently in the last couple of
years because some of them just
disappeared from my brain you didn't
play this on stream I didn't play his on
screen I played a play on xbox
oh it's destiny
oh that was destiny mm-hmm you're right
it didn't sound same yeah that's how
long it's been for me yeah i'm i hear
destiny to have fun oh that was destiny
to [__] loves listening - oh my bad i
wouldn't i got destiny won my bad I
wouldn't got it my bad dog
I just look around
[Music]
this game was huge when it came out was
for console
it's a beloved superhero character is
this Arkham Asylum Arkham City
Arkham City I watched when I was younger
I was like probably 13 my friend Tyler
growing out tell Hammond he got Arkham
Asylum and I watched him play the whole
game i sat there and why I usually was
the player and my brother was the
watcher but when I was at his house I
watched him play the little game was
really fun to watch all right you ready
keep it coming
is easy then what is it giving people
time what I'm waiting for people what
nothing
it's double-oh-seven is it goldeneye I
was waiting for I was trying to be rude
no that was like it that was an example
of something that's so obvious and it
smacks you in the face of how obvious it
is and I just the words escape me but I
played this game growing up this was
like my first actually this was probably
my first shooter game experience because
this is before halo and we would play
like it would be like the four-way split
screen yeah and you could cheat so
easily you would screen the screen
looking [__] but um you have the guided
missiles do you remember that Oh have
you you played it recently it sucks it
sucks I've watched some I don't remember
who but I watched someone recently was
adjacent did it for a 24 hour stream and
it was awful Yeah right in the seljuq to
play it but you're like this is no it
looks horrible yeah yeah you did right
that's okay there you go
good how we on time I don't know okay
you're so helpful today what how old we
are 30 minutes and two minutes stitch
fix it's a it's a sir it's a personal
styling service that helps you get new
clothes with alcohol in the store you
don't have to go shopping you'll have to
try anything on you have to say hey do
you have this in it no they have it in
that size it's stitch fix it's your
personal styling service you go on to
stitch fix ok on the website stitch fix
calm slash Jen and Julian now available
in the UK amazing news and you enter
your answer to a bunch of little
questions about style right would you
wear this shirt what type of clothing do
you usually wear do
where this type of pants that kind of
thing right answer a couple questions
that forms a profile then a stylist
expert will fit that together to get you
a box of clothes that are exactly
customized to you and your taste and
your needs and they will send you the
box of clothes and then they are yours
okay you try them on at home no pressure
see how the items fit and you only pay
for what you love and you return the
rest shipping exchanges and returns are
always free
they have solutions for men women and
kids all over the US and now the UK so
go to stitch fix comm sauce - Angelina
get an extra 25% off when you keep
everything in your box that's stitch
fixed comm slash Jenna and Julianne or
click the link down below a much easier
just to click link just
just click link speaking of click guys
click on your email every morning with
this skin the skin is a newsletter that
comes every single morning with your
little tidbits of news that you need to
know about what's going on in the world
and it's a really helpful tool it is
completely free and it makes it so you
don't have to sift through a bunch of
nonsense
the skins real selling point here is how
easy it becomes to digest important news
in a world diluted with like nonsense
and when you go on Twitter it's so hard
to find a news story sometimes because
it's like opinion and then this and then
that but like the stitch sorry the the
skin is right there for you it's bullet
point style it's very simple easy to
read digest five minutes or less drink
your coffee and then you're done you got
you got it in your brain it's done so go
to the skin th es ki mmm that's two M's
calm / Jenna Julianne enter your email
and subscribe it is completely free try
it out let us know what you think and
also when you do that you were entered
to win a $250 Visa gift card that you
can spend on whatever you want yeah
thank you sponsors don't buy drugs with
a Visa gift card money has a bellyache I
was rebelling making a noise belly are
you ready for your next one mhm
hallo know what Julian we already did
hallo
oh this is familiar
[Music]
have you seen me play this game mm-hmm
you have
[Music]
why am I not thinking of the name this
is a great song my first thought was
this is extra key but I know that's not
it does that add a different theme song
take a hint
yeah you were born a little soft car
rocket Lee
I forgot that this is the music they use
it's very EDM mm-hmm right is that EDM
music I don't know Julia electro I think
it's electronic dance music but electro
D that's right lady lady lady rocket
week how do I miss that one I don't know
it's been a long time since you played
it smell oh I hung up the sock car a
long time ago I was like that time that
I I thought if rocket League had a story
mode that laughing for like ten minutes
campaign mode yeah I was born a little
sock car you had to go through different
bosses yeah levels mm-hmm to become the
car the sock car that you were destined
to be Wow
he dreamed of of making it big in the
rocket League or rocket League X pokémon
there's just cars everywhere and said
I'm talking on and he just catch me
steal cars sick it's like a it's called
grand theft rocket league grant dead on
Captain wall
[Music]
okay
yeah bacon okay have I played this on
stream yes
[Music]
so is a life you strange no no so like
it's not well life is strange is tough
because there's a lot of different music
in that game there's a lot of music in
in all games most games that aren't like
have I played in the last year he ours
yes oh oh don't want me alive
[Music]
that come from be subnautica no Kony no
I'm trying to think of all the games we
play the last year give me a hit
how are you guys doing by the way
are you getting them wait a minute wait
a minute
[Music]
I got nothing I don't know do you want
to hit yeah what were you doing before
this podcast mr. Gough
this is tarkov you know it's a bummer
though like because I literally have all
these games on it and lot music turned
off it's too bad you're missing I'm not
missing out that's not no that's tarkoff
[Laughter]
I have my music turned off on the menu
in games I don't know what to say I'm
sorry
[Music]
tomb raider
what's that game that
horizon zero dawn I don't know
oh wait I know that note I've heard that
before
I played this game
so you have this music on just
interesting to find out which master
this game you have I've played this game
borrow this before
[Music]
stop doing that
I'm really thinking here this is a
really good song are you a little hint
mo baby hit yeah the character that you
play in this game I hate pay packs its
apex yeah yep apex well you don't like
Mirage no I don't like Mirage I like
Mirage just not when you play Mirage why
there you've been bamboozled yeah
exactly I don't like getting bamboozled
good job you got there
Pat thank you I had a little help but I
got them I don't think that you should
need help for this one okay I don't
think
[Music]
this is pretty distinct music Julie can
you please guess already is it a little
Julian no come on I don't know yes you
do yes you do
you can't even lie to me stop it yes you
do or did truck heist on no you're just
told I'm not rolling okay then we don't
need to know the answer to that no babe
come on I don't know yes you did no I
don't I don't just hint I'm not lying
why'd you just look at the ceiling when
you said thank you I swear to God I have
not thrown any of these I don't know the
one like either blanking out or I don't
know then what is this music sound like
to you Julian
hearthstone no do you think you'd be
sailing the high seas see if they see a
thieves yeah I'm a big sea abuse fan you
can't stand you I didn't know that one
Jason's probably so mad at me
[Music]
something's gonna happen
is this a game out quite No
um have I guessed it yet no because you
keep keep guessing life is strange or is
it like constrain this is really strange
is this a console mainly game or is it
like a PC game I don't I don't know I
think Fraser you play it on some
different stuff have you played this
game no and I've never played it
that was that was far audience okay
that's the 2019 World Championship
League of Legends oh nice yeah that was
a lot of people I got that
I've heard this before
is this the new pub jisan
there's testing no there's so many
trumpets in here for it to beep ugh jeez
you hear those horns you hear that brass
section this is pumping
[Music]
does this sound like anything else was
it felt a little like Game of Thrones I
want to say it sounds like a little bit
what ever since no no it sounds like
maybe like a sporting event is it FIFA
yes that'd what walking there's like
this meme edit of like the EA Sports in
the game but it's just him saying he
over de la ban in so many [__] years
so I don't yeah that was the game I play
down a lot growing up I owe
[Music]
it's horse
have I played this game technically yes
technically yes yeah you played a
classic version of it World of Warcraft
Wow you didn't give that away I knew
that one
mm-hmm this is Wow this is Wow I did
play wild classic for about two days
yeah and then I didn't I played it for
one day and then didn't and decided it
was too classic for me well you're on a
bit much more advanced than my mom true
and I'm on a different game entirely but
I don't know the theme song else
apparently no you don't
have I played this game
[Music]
Super Smash Bros yeah I think this is
the original one
[Music]
I love Super Smash Bros right yeah this
is all the intros this video so I'm
gonna skip to the end and see what it
sounds like now oh oh hell yeah
[Music]
oh yeah so I'm talking about baby mm-hmm
so I'm talking about how we're moving on
[Music]
sports game
nope
have I played it
No
[Music]
I honestly don't know this is csgo
our shirt mmm Counter Strike global
defense global Offensive what is this
sorry to all my CSS out there okay
here's your next one I'm assuming I've
played this game I think you have is it
on pc i don't think so i mean it is now
was it a handheld device game no console
[Music]
GTA you know yes GTA yes and resse wow
that's wild this song on YouTube has 31
million views yeah that's [__] crazy
31 and Reyes was so popular yeah
Wow that's dope
[Music]
this is blizzard
I don't think so does it start with star
no what's the game one thing you know
star crashed aircraft no it's not start
[Music]
hmm neither one of us has played this
game
[Music]
runescape not a bad guess no it's dota 2
dota
I've played runescape a long long time
ago but I have never played dota Jake's
gonna be mad at me mm-hmm is this a
horror game puzzle game No
how I play it
I don't know the answer to that I mean
you've played some of these games I
don't know if you played this one some
of these games yeah hmm
is it like minigames within a bigger
game
this is Bowser yeah it's Bowser oh no no
it's black ops 2 oh call it any black
ops I definitely play black ops 2 in
college yeah this literally says at the
bottom this is composed by Trent Reznor
that's so cool like I know that he does
movies and like all kinds of stuff I
didn't realize that he was also a
composer for video games he's such a
cool amazing talented guy and you know
that he rescued he's a Nine Inch Nails
yeah I think maybe rescues greyhounds I
think you talking about that he has like
I don't know three or four of them yeah
that's super dope right
super super dope Trent Reznor he's the
cool guy and he likes greyhounds hi
where did you come from
[Music]
you have played this game
do we play this game together no I've
never played this game really but you
used to play it well I suppose man
overwatch eats over what their job each
T y MP
[Music]
this sounds like an old game
what just happened there was this on
gameboy was it on old consoles yeah it's
a combat game ii good guess mark on us
also good guess it's not tag get her
alive
sounds older it's the it's a place and
then punch where do you fight someone
fight night in the boxing ring
no arena out back outside out front
Street Fighter 3 fighter out front
street out front
do you really did her alive know that
game was really fun really that was like
in the time where mortal I think Mortal
Kombat was like more popular but for
some reason Dead or Alive came about and
it was like I think it was an Xbox
specific game and it was just so good it
actually looked like striking Vipers
like it's like the the graphics were
really good for its time like the
gameplay was really fun and the
characters were really cool and unique
maybe I don't know maybe if you people
felt it was too much of a Mortal Kombat
ripoff or something but I really loved
Dead or Alive I played that a lot Street
Fighter alright
have you seen me play this game no
there's a popular on console it's
popular on everything would I play this
game No
Kellog on twitch real quick
it's some sort of like mm our strategy
pad game I know it is what is it you
pick him up I don't I'm holding all
right I'll get where me give me a hit
hi we're Bethesda have you tried our
game blink would you like to try it is
it on your LS Skyrim
yeah use RoSPA testa yeah yeah they
deserve it they possess that might be
watching sorry
[Music]
I don't think this is in the game have
you played this yeah we both played it
recently no I I'm not sure that this is
in the game but it literally just says
the name of the game but this has 150
million views really if you haven't yet
rewind it like 10 seconds No
okay yeah turn up no you told me it was
too loud before it's not in the game so
what I don't think I don't know it's
five nights at Freddy Freddy I Love You
Man your music or something
[Music]
I don't think you played this game it
sounds like something I've never played
so I don't know and I want to guess
what he's bumping the table so love it
it's Bioshock hmm would have no idea
life is strange life is strange Julian
is easy
oh the fields December 3rd last chapter
our last episode this is the main menu
theme for 10 hours it's a 10 hour mix on
YouTube no it's not a mix it's this it's
the main menus recorded even ours
alright I'm down with that five nights
at Freddy's
[Music]
I've played this
but what is it
[Music]
is this the new pub jisang no
why are you smiling oh god this is
obvious isn't it
[Music]
you guys already get it
are you laughing what's so funny tell me
give me home say something
[Music]
wait this is elder scrolls you deserve
like an hours on him oh I just needed to
hit once it hit the original original
game that every time they come out with
a new to the theme songs for games that
your significant other plays for six
thousand hours just hit a little
different
they really do I [__] love I love it
it's so amazing oh you're still on other
Scrolls yeah okay I was like it sounds
like it's my favorite ship sorry
no I it is it's good do you want to
listen to more let's listen to more wait
okay other schools have your elder
scrolls oh you so much I love you but
what do you want like tell me this
doesn't slap this is morrowind okay yeah
this is good yeah it's all cuz it is it
sounds
[Music]
okay next one babe that's it that was
the last one went through like 7,000 you
know you did a really good job compiling
these thanks me you did a better job
compiling than I did a bansuri are we
gonna sign off with this music I like
that this will be our and inked did you
have fun
I fine I'm listening my favorite music
Beach you know what soundtrack would be
fun
but it'd be so hard to do in this game
is Tony Hawk pro skater it was just it
was music it wasn't original music you
know most of it wasn't I think
[Music]
[__] [__] [__] this is the music that
you hear when you get disconnected
[Laughter]
seriously though there's a problem with
the game last night and people just
started math disconnecting Oh everyone's
just standing there's like 10 people
that all get kicked at the same time
that's an issue yeah no [__] Beach I
heard something about like maybe they
don't own the source code or something
yeah anyway well thank you for taking
the time to gather those songs oh those
are really fun I was bad at most of them
but I got a couple of them and I'm proud
of the ones I got and even the ones I
didn't get I hope you guys is fun it's a
lot of fun yeah these are really fun and
I feel like we could definitely do it
more of these we could probably do two
of this at some point maybe so there's
so many games even more than like you
would think right like when when I went
into this I had a couple games I was
like yeah life is strange
hallo what else but it's cool it was
really cool to like relive it in the
musical form but thank you for doing
that
oh yeah hopefully you guys did a lot
better than me you just thought
everything was in life is strange
everything is life is still okay alright
yeah you're right you're right I'm sorry
anyways anyways next week it's
Thanksgiving week
either we have next week off or the week
after I always forget I don't know won't
weed out on our agenda Julie McDowell on
Twitter but we'll be live this week on
twitch I hope you guys are getting
excited for Thanksgiving in the holiday
season I hope you guys are all doing
well thank you for listening and
watching have a great rest of your day
and we'll see you next week or the week
after
[Music]